The a N, C, when you visit a voting station,
they go take a buggy that is not part of anything.
Once they know you're coming,
they mobilise people to that voting station.
You know how the gazippos are done?
We do them next to each other and all of that.
When you are about to address your people,
the pump music,
that is political intolerance.
Political intolerance is not violence,
is political intolerance that leads to violence.
Because if the e, f,
f people say, but no,
but our president is speaking,
switch off this thing,
then they don't tolerate each other like that.
Then violence starts
everywhere. And I thought the I F,
P was the one that was violent in K Z,
N and killing our people in K Z, N.
I think the a N C killed more people in K Z,
N than the I F P.
And I think the a N
C is at the centre of political violence.
N, K Z N. The level of intolerance is extreme.
I've, I've never come to experience it
anywhere in the country, anywhere.
I've been blocked to enter voting stations before
by a N, C people.
The level of intolerance in that place
by the a N C,
it must be reported to the I, E, C
and Mukhwanazi must nip it on the badge
if he wants to control that province,
especially now with new developments
of a new political party in K Z, N,
we've already seen videos where
they were destroying the gazebo of m K.
You will never see this fascist organization,
this reckless organization,
this useless organization called E F,
F engaged in such activities.
We don't. We don't.
You can say whatever you want to say about us.
We don't. We,
we exercise maximum discipline in everything else we do.